Take a look at this
impossible figure.
Much like the work of the artist
M.C. Escher
this shows an object that seems
to be three dimensional
but cannot actually exist
off the screen.
On the other hand, this is
a possible object.
It could exist in real life.
In 2001, researchers performed
a unique experiment with
images like this.
They asked people with
and without dyslexia
to identify which drawings
were impossible.
The people with dyslexia proved
significantly faster
at recognizing the
impossible figures.
The researchers linked dyslexia
with a particular global
visual spatial ability...
to process a whole image versus
focusing on it part by part.
This study was just one of several
over the past few decades
that hinted at something
many dyslexic people
have only anecdotally known.
Though they had difficulty with
reading and writing...
they repeatedly found enhanced
cognitive strengths
in other areas.
I have this kind of like
model in my head.
I can spin it around
in my head
and see ways of deconstructing
and flipping it around
with a lot of these.
It’s the entire puzzle rather than
just the piece of it.
It brings another layer of thinking
and thinking outside the box
and the blues.
-Was it the blue...
-Blue sky thinking?
Blue sky thinking!
That doesn't make me
superhuman
it’s just like how my
brain structure is.
Around 20% of the
US population
has been diagnosed
with dyslexia
and their difficulties
all trace back...
to here.
The dyslexic brain is
structured differently
in a way that can create
specific challenges...
but can also create
specific advantages.
In terms of human evolution
the brain isn't naturally wired
to read.
There's not one specific region
for reading
like there is for sleeping or
engaging our fear response.
Reading is an invention.
It is invention that's only
6000 years old.
While there is so much
we still don't understand about
the human brain...
over the past few decades,
a clearer picture
of how we read has emerged.
When we're young,
we're activating
both hemispheres of
our brains heavily...
expending energy to learn
how to read.
But for fluent readers,
the brain streamlines
more activation to structures
in the left hemisphere...
like this region known as
the visual word form area...
which helps us recognize
letters and words.
And this region, key to
mapping letters to sounds
called phonological awareness.
For example, breaking up the word cat
into the sounds...
cuh, ah, and tuh.
And there's Broca's area,
which among other things
helps with comprehension to understand
what words actually mean.
Activated areas linked together
with white matter.
There are neural pathways
that turn into a complicated
highway network
that allows fluent readers
to process a word
within milliseconds.
But in the dyslexic brain,
these highways
and activated areas can look
a lot different.
Research using brain scans
of dyslexic readers
showed that there was
less activation
in these areas of the
left hemisphere...
suggesting there's often a pathway
disruption in these systems
that help maps sounds to letters
and decode words.
But people with dyslexia
also consistently showed
overactivation
in the brain's right hemisphere
when reading.
And that makes it
more laborious.
This could mean that while
dyslexic people
may have trouble recognizing
words and sounds...
they're working even harder
to compensate elsewhere.
The pathway disruptions can also come
with challenges in grammar,
retrieving math facts
working memory,
among other things too.
Or often with dyslexia,
neural pathways
are not disrupted, but just
slowed down.
But I'm sort of
mildly dyslexic.
My challenge is more with numbers.
Reading out loud.
In class, you're stricken with panic.
And then all the words
start floating.
You just you just can't
read the words.
Everyone else would be on to
doing the exercise.
And I’d be still trying to
read the instructions.
Exactly how people experience dyslexia
varies greatly.
It has no bearing on
an individual's intelligence...
but today it's commonly labeled
a hereditary neurobiological
learning disability.
Research has found explicit
support and instruction
in areas like phonology,
syntax, and spelling
can lead to success for
dyslexic learners.
But the reading brain is only
part of the picture.
Years of research has started
corroborating the idea
that dyslexic people are
prone to advantages
including high level reasoning,
problem solving
spatial processing, episodic memory,
and creativity.
Because I have the full picture
in my head
sometimes I can make association
between things that they don't appear
to be relevant.
We shake it up a bit if we kind of
get people to think...
you know, “Oh, I didn't
think of that.”
Being able to recall stories.
You know, recall images.
I'll meet somebody
and I will stop them on
the street and be like
“We know each other” and
they will have no idea.
I'm going to show you what
a dyslexic high schooler did.
I was floored.
Gobsmacked, because he was drawing
from memory
upside down.
There are specific areas of strength
in the right hemisphere...
that seem very much
to be at play...
with individuals
with dyslexia.
While most functions do use
both hemispheres of our brains...
the right hemisphere is typically
associated with skills
like spatial abilities and
visual imagery.
In a study similar to the one
with impossible figures...
dyslexic people were
better able
to identify letters in their periphery
than other readers.
Another study compared
the abilities
of college students with
and without dyslexia
to memorize blurred images.
Students with dyslexia significantly
outperformed.
And in 2022, researchers at
University of Strathclyde
and University of Cambridge
concluded that
that many people
with dyslexia
are specialized in exploring
the unknown.
And they suggested that because of
how prevalent
dyslexia is in the population,
the form of cognition plays
an essential role in enabling
humans to adapt...
especially through collaboration
between different kinds of people.
These new ways of thinking
about dyslexia
are part of a wider movement
to embrace neurodiversity...
the idea that brains are simply
wired differently
and that these natural variations
don't mean they're lacking.
Stigma, misconceptions, and a core lack
of understanding dyslexia
are still rampant.
But the more we can learn about
differently, organized brains
the better we can teach, collaborate with,
and empower them.
And ultimately change the way
we see dyslexia.
This constellation
of strengths...
and weaknesses that go
hand in hand.
You can imagine how much better
a child will feel when they know
this is not a curse.
This is not a disease.
This is just a different organization
in the brain.